quand ils ramènent une coupe du monde un
soir de juillet là l'homme noir et
français le mois pourquoi il ya des
moments dans ma vie où je suis dans
l'anonymat le plus complet
et là je suis encore traités communs
comme un noir le racisme je pense que
c'est un instinct qui peut être
naturelle chez l'homme et qu'il faut
avoir beaucoup d'intelligence pour
combattre cet instinct qui vient de la
peur de l'autre et la peur de la
différence est que ya un racisme qui
existent et qui existe entre les noirs
et les arabes est un raciste qui existe
entre les arabes eux mêmes est un
raciste qui disent contrôler noir
racisme qui existe entre les noirs eux
mêmes ces jeux tous sont des cartons
livrés on parle souvent du racisme des
blancs contre les noirs et les arabes en
france parce que celui là plus de
conséquences parce que il faut dire ceux
qui gouvernent sont majoritairement
blanc est donc si s'ils font preuve de
racisme
la conséquence sur nos vies conséquences
sur nos vies ne sont pas ne sont pas
négligeables
[Musique]
c'est à ce titre appliquer un [ __ ] est
la norme
quel est le pays mais son morceau m'a
permis aussi de faire un parallèle en
posant la question jusqu'où va-t-on
suivre les
les américains les français ils ont par
le phare facilement des violences
policières ou aux états unis mais ils
ont du mal à s'indigner sur les
violences policières qui sont commises
sur le territoire français ça reste
quand même quelque chose d'assez
surpoids surprenante à damas si le
racisme
j'en parle je continuerai en parler mais
jamais de façon victimaire